At the very beginning of
this nano degree program,
we had you do an exercise to see
how just broadly used machine
learning can be.
We had you look up a topic that
you're interested in along with
machine learning to see if
had been applied there yet.
For me, I used basketball, astronomy,
and cooking and found that
machine learning had already been
applied to all three of those domains.
For the final project in
this nano degree program,
you're going to revisit that idea.
You're going to take on a project
that's completely your own.
You're going to choose your own dataset,
your own area, your own domain and
see what you can find
through machine learning.
You're going to see what techniques
you should apply to that dataset.
You're going to see what
models you can build for
the data available in that area.
Now we've collected some data sets for
you that you can use, and
you might be interested in some
of the ones that we've gathered,
but there's plenty
available online as well.
We've actually provided some links for
you to go look up some
of your own datasets.
The idea of this last project is that
machine learning is much more than
being able to use the techniques
that you've learned.
It's also knowing when to use them, and
how to evaluate the results
that come out of them.
So, for this final project,
that's exactly what you're going to do.
You're going to take on your
own dataset, your own question,
generate your own models, generate
your own conclusions, and report them.